قال المتحدث باسم هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان الجيش يحقق مزيد من التقدم في عملياته
في بخموت وبريديانسك واضاف ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على نحو سته
كيلومترات ونصف كيلومتر في منطقتي
عملياتسك وتافاريا
خلال اسبوع تقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه بضعه
كيلومترات في بخموت وفي منطقه عمليات
دونياس كان التقدم قوات الدفاع لسته
كيلومترات ونصف كيلومتر وكانت مساحه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه المحرره في الاتجاهين
الشرقي والجنوبي اكثر من 100 كيلومتر مربع
كما تقدمت قواتنا امس نحو كيلومتر واحد في
اتجاه بير جانس
للمزيد حول هذه التطورات اذا حسان كنت تقف
وما زلت عند هذه المواقع التي تضررت فكر
فيري من القصف الروسي امام هذه البنايات
والسيارات
المتفحمه ارتفعت الحصيله منذ انجازك
للتقرير الى عشره قتلى وخمسه وعشرين مصابا
هل مازال البحث جار عن مفقودين
نعم يا مريم البحث ما زال جريا عن احد
المفقودين كان الحديث عن سته مفقودين الان
يجري الحديث عن مفقود واحد بعدما تم
الاعلان عن مقتل الخمس مفقودين الذين
كانوا تحت حطام هذه المباني التي تعرضت
لقصف بصاروخ مجنح من طراز خاء
10155 هذا النوع من الصواريخ يا صواريخ
مجنحه كبيره ادت الى هذه
الاثار الكبيره للدمار نستطيع مشاهده هنا
اثار الدمار واعمال رفع الانقاذ ما زالت
مستمره في هذا المكان هذا المبنى تعرض
لدمار كبير وهو كما تقول الاداره العسكريه
مبنى سكني وكان السكان فيه عند حدوث هذه
الضربه الصاروخيه الكبيره خلال هذه الليله
وهذا الموقع هو احد المواقع واحد من بين
خمس مواقع اخرى تعرضت لاثار الدمار بفعل
هذه الهجمه الصاروخيه بسته صواريخ فقط نحو
مدينه ومنطقه كليفري فيما ايضا
اوكرانيا كانت تعرضت لهجمه صاروخيه باربعه
عشره صاروخا من هذه الصواريخ المجنحه خلال
الليله بالاضافه ايضا الى عدد كبير من
المسيرات اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه كما تقول
الاداره والسلطات الاوكرانيه عشره صواريخ
فيما ايضا اسقطت اربع مسيرات خلال هذه
الهجمه كانت الهجمه على مراحل مختلفه خلال
الليل ولكن على ما يبدو ان بعض هذه
الصواريخ والمسيرات وصلت الى اهدافها وكما
نشاهد هذا الاثر الكبير للدمار
في كل شيء طال كل شيء هذا الدمار في هذا
المكان
وادى الى تضرر عدد ايضا من المباني
السكنيه ليس فقط هذا المبنى انما ايضا
مباني اخرى وهناك ايضا ادى ذلك الى جرح
عدد كبير من الاشخاص يجري الحديث حتى هذه
اللحظه عن 28 جريحا من بينهم 12 شخصا بحال
الخطر كما تقول السلطات وهذا ايضا مؤشر
ربما يرفع عدد الضحايا في هذه الضربه التي
جرت في هذا المكان ولكن ما جرى قبل قليل
مريم انه قبل قليل تحدثنا مع وزير شؤون
الداخليه واكد لنا خلال حديثه عن سبب هذه
الضربات وفقه الروايه الاوكرانيه قال ان
هذه الضربات التي تطال المدن الاوكرانيه
من الشمال الى الجنوب هي النتيجه للنجاح
الافعال عند الخطوط الاماميه والهجمات
المضاده وقال ان القوات الروسيه تخشى ان
تنجح هذه الهجمات المضاده ولذلك تقوم بهذه
الهجمات اذا المسؤولين الاوكرانيين يربطون
بين هذه الهجمات الكبيره القويه والتي
تطال السكان الان
بالافعال التي تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه
عند جبهات القتال